Jeff D'Andria: So now we're gonna break it up, so it's not just me, chatting.
Jeff D'Andria: I'd like to call on a volunteer that's willing to show their resume.
Jeff D'Andria: And even better, a job description of a target role, and I'd love to kind of…
Jeff D'Andria: Hear about your process, give you some feedback,
Jeff D'Andria: kind of like… I'll put the former recruiter hat on and really give you kind of like, is this trending toward a yes or a no? Is anyone, like, to volunteer?
Stephanie Fayette: I… I raised my hand, but I can also speak, and this is Stephanie speaking. I would love to volunteer.
Jeff D'Andria: Yay! Alright, let's do it, Stephanie.
Stephanie Fayette: Would you like me to send you the link, or share my screen, or how does that work?
Jeff D'Andria: What, let's have you drive,
Jeff D'Andria: Let's, or do you have a link? Is it a Google Doc?
Stephanie Fayette: Yes, it is.
Jeff D'Andria: Okay.
Jeff D'Andria: Let's… let's start with you. Let's go ahead and you share your screen.
Stephanie Fayette: Okay, let me pull it up first, and then I'll…
Sathya Narayanan: If you don't mind hopping on the webcam also, Stephanie, it'd be good to see who you are talking to.
Stephanie Fayette: Sorry, give me just a second, let me look for it first, and then I will…
Jeff D'Andria: Take your time. So what we're gonna start with is the job description, and… to me.
Jeff D'Andria: it's just critical to North Star your resume to the job description, and I'd love to just kind of look at a job description with y'all, and just tease out maybe 3 things. 3 things, even better if we can go more than that, but for the sake of time.
Jeff D'Andria: Looks like these three things are the most critical.
Jeff D'Andria: And then, let's look at the resume to see if we're aligned.
Jeff D'Andria: So, Stephanie, is there a job description you might be able to pull up for a target role?
Jeff D'Andria: Do you have one handy, you think?
Stephanie Fayette: Yeah, sorry, I muted myself, and I was trying to, like, find where the microphone was, but yes, I do have one. I can probably hop on LinkedIn right now.
Jeff D'Andria: Let's do it.
Jeff D'Andria: I think to give a teaser, I think…
Jeff D'Andria: When we identify those three things.
Jeff D'Andria: That the hiring manager, the recruiter have called out as, like, okay, like, we really want to see this in our top candidates.
Jeff D'Andria: Then, it's gonna be critical that you give your example of that.
Jeff D'Andria: And then, one layer deeper, where are you gonna put it?
Jeff D'Andria: Are you gonna put it in the top third?
Jeff D'Andria: For the sake of today, I would argue that's the most competitive stance.
Jeff D'Andria: But yeah, when you go beyond the top 3, maybe you start saying, look, here's the top
Jeff D'Andria: 6 things, top seven things that things are, wanting. I don't have, maybe, space in the top third, but yeah, you better make sure those… those top 7 things you've identified, they gotta find their way on the resume somewhere.
Stephanie Fayette: Are you able to see both of my screens? I have them on, like, different accounts.
Jeff D'Andria: So, camp coordinator, can you, go down to the description a little bit?
Jeff D'Andria: Let's see, about the job… And then maybe go more.
Jeff D'Andria: Okay.
Jeff D'Andria: So, Stephanie, can you tell me… I'm curious what you're seeing as far as, like.
Jeff D'Andria: What's standing out to you about this camp coordinator role? Like, what does it seem like, maybe, as we think of 3 things they really want to see in an ideal candidate?
Stephanie Fayette: Wait, sorry, was that directly to me?
Jeff D'Andria: Yeah, yeah, what are you… what are you seeing, that looks like is really important to them that they want? And I'd say when they're… when someone's hiring for a role, a job.
Jeff D'Andria: They're working on a problem, and they need to hire someone to solve that problem.
Stephanie Fayette: Yeah.
Jeff D'Andria: So, what do they want?
Jeff D'Andria: What are you seeing?
Stephanie Fayette: I think someone who's just going to be able to do all these things that they're asking for, but most importantly, kind of, like, be a leader when they need them to be, and, like, supervise, like, and…
Stephanie Fayette: Yeah.
Jeff D'Andria: Yup.
Jeff D'Andria: So you're looking for someone that might be able to lead in this, in this, in this summer camp environment, so leadership.
Stephanie Fayette: Yeah.
Jeff D'Andria: So, let's call that. Number one, let's say leadership, and then let's see if we can maybe identify two more.
Stephanie Fayette: like, A great communicator, like.
Stephanie Fayette: I don't know, I feel like in order to be a leader, you also have to be, like, a great communicator, but that's not always the case.
Jeff D'Andria: Yeah, no, totally. I think communication, I see a parent communication, I'm sure.
Stephanie Fayette: Yeah.
Jeff D'Andria: Across staff, and then probably with the campers, right?
Jeff D'Andria: Leadership, communication.
Stephanie Fayette: Management, I would say.
Jeff D'Andria: anymore.
Stephanie Fayette: Yeah.
Jeff D'Andria: What kind of management?
Stephanie Fayette: Like, just time management, or just, like.
Stephanie Fayette: like, organizing in general as well, because, like, you kind of have to, like, bounce around your time between… I don't know if you're in a classroom supervising, but also being able to, like, step outside to talk to a parent, how do you manage that? Like, how do you, you know, prioritize your… your jobs or your things that you got going on?
Jeff D'Andria: Totally. Kind of this organizational skill set, management, for sure. So we had leadership, communication, and then,
Jeff D'Andria: call it management. So I'm curious now, as we go from there, so now we've got some North Stars.
Jeff D'Andria: That they really care about.
Jeff D'Andria: As we go to your resume, can you… can you go to your resume now?
Stephanie Fayette: Oh, yeah.
Jeff D'Andria: Have that before.
Stephanie Fayette: This is… I have… probably, like, 20 version of my resume.
Stephanie Fayette: And that's just one. But I feel like I have one that's, like, more…
Stephanie Fayette: tailored towards that specific position, if I were to apply for it?
Jeff D'Andria: Yeah, let's pull that up.
Stephanie Fayette: I think.
Stephanie Fayette: This one is not very much a…
Stephanie Fayette: up-to-date, as you can see. But that was when I was working as a program leader.
Jeff D'Andria: There you go.
Jeff D'Andria: Do you mind expanding the screen just a little bit?
Jeff D'Andria: Okay.